back here
steeler faithful steer to honk
great actor joe manganiello back here on
the show how are you joseph
well i'm i'm pretty good rich i mean i'm
exhausted but good i feel like i'm
hungover today and i had nothing to
drink
i was about to say you're you're not i
mean you're not a nervous eater are you
i mean you don't eat anything that's bad
for you but uh
what about you hire papa john last night
yeah buddy yeah yeah garlic sauce on the
crust the whole thing i mean i just it
was uh yeah i was eating all day are you
kidding me it was it was nuts it what a
crazy day i mean that was like one of
one of the all-time wildest days
of my life watching football what were
you and your steeler buddies texting you
about walk me through that day we all
woke up just thinking okay it's 10 a.m
in l.a i'm gonna you know i woke up
early made the coffee walk the dog i
thought okay i'm gonna watch ben you
know ben's last game
and and that's okay and we're gonna say
goodbye to him and i looked at the score
of the jaguars game and i thought oh my
god wait a second and then i looked at
our score which was
you know that game was sluggish that was
like a horrible first half game
and uh and i just thought man you know
ben's ben's a fourth quarter
master
so i thought maybe he's got enough in
the tank
to put us over the top
in the fourth quarter and and certainly
he did and then put took that into
overtime fourth and eight i mean the guy
like was out of his mind in the fourth
quarter in overtime
and um and that put us in that kind of
position where all we need is for the
raiders and chargers not to die
and then
and then yeah i know it's like if it
weren't for that time out rich i've i
think they just wouldn't let it run out
i don't know i think that time out that
brandon staley popped off
to me
um was
was him making sure
that they wouldn't attempt a field goal
right to make sure that they knew that
there was a run coming not a kneel down
coming or at least they assumed that
there was not and they fired off that
that that time out that i think
they would have just run the ball with
josh jacobs that one last time
and run the risk of the pisarchic you
know miracle at the meadowlands would
have been a disaster in the desert right
that's what we would have been calling
it if that had happened yeah um that's
what i think and had you st had had had
the
chargers stopped it i don't think they
would have they would have knelt down
instead of taking a 60-yard field goal i
think that's what happened and i i know
you'd have been livid i imagine right
yes well i mean just the length of the
field goal it just seemed like you know
there's no way this is going to happen
you know and then it's like timeout big
gain and then bang you know um they're
they're in great field goal position it
was it was insane i mean
the person i feel the worst about was uh
there's a guy who put a 200 bet down
157 thousand to one that the jaguars
would win the steelers would win and the
time and the raiders and chargers would
tie
i didn't hear about that it would have
paid out 31.4 million it's uh yeah one
of the guys i went to high school with
so that was in the text thread hey my
buddy put down this bet what's that what
what no your buddy put down one what bet
say that one i know i know what the
parlay was but how much my best friend
in high school yeah his buddy put down
the bet 200 he put down hundred dollars
uh 157 to one and it would have paid out
31.4 million it's like it's like the
powerball reading every number except
the last one he needed that tie
oh my god yeah
is that guy today have you have we
followed up i don't know he should be on
24-hour watch i think
oh did he ha did he hedge at all
i i'm not sure i mean i i all i know is
that that he did put down that bet so
i'm not sure what the you know
joe manganiello here in the rich eisen
show that throw that ben through to
deante johnson right on the right what
right on the sideline um in overtime and
then johnson drop drops the next one and
then ray ray mcleod kind of grabs it and
and
stumbles backwards while juggling the
ball i mean holy crap but it finally did
pay off and now
uh how how are you
i i'm assuming you and stone street are
type through your wife right so
how is that working for for next sunday
night for steelers chiefs how are we
working this one i don't know you know i
mean we i really don't talk football
with him you know
it's it's one of those things where like
you know it's kind of like nouveau riche
versus old money
you know wow
we wear it a little differently you know
what i mean to somebody who just comes
out of nowhere and starts winning so
there's a bit of a difference in how we
carry ourselves
[Music]
like a rolex versus richard mealy kind
of oh my
nothing wrong with the reshard meal i'll
say that of course not oh
but i'm just saying you know that would
be more like a diamond-encrusted
breitling or something you know
wow
that is a better answer than i could
have ever imagined
oh my gosh
come on i mean
big ben i mean big ben's playing with
the old house money now right i mean
this is it right that's the beautiful
thing is that this thing continues we
get another week out of it you know we
get to watch ben and also like you know
things happen that's why we play the
games so you know it it's so exciting to
have no pressure whatsoever and and no
one no one's going to pick us
and and that's kind of a beautiful thing
that's true how about this how about
melvin ingram the old hostage right
right isn't that what uh tomlin referred
to him as we don't want hostages we want
volunteers yeah and he's the one that
blew up melvin gordon to send the chiefs
into the two seed yeah you know but
here's the thing with with ingram like i
understand you know the guy's coming off
of an injury he's on a one-year deal he
needs to play he needs to prove himself
this is a gamer you know this is a guy
who's going to be around so i get that
but here's the thing the guys had what
two sacks and one forced fumble since he
joined the chiefs and his backup
in pittsburgh has
two sacks and one forced fumble so you
know i understand that like ingram seems
like the missing piece over there which
is what you know kind of like what minka
fitzpatrick was to us two years ago when
we got him all of a sudden things just
clicked on the defense and you know
unfortunately you know we now have to
face their team and it looks like ingram
was that missing piece tomlin versus
reed muhammad versus big ben that's why
they put this sunday night man i was at
the last game in arrowhead the last
playoff game in arrowhead where the
steelers won by only kicking field goals
and then uh antonio brown steve's
facetime uh
facebook live from the locker room
during tomlin's speech i was at that
game i don't know if you're aware he's
still active on social media joe i don't
know if you saw that or not well yeah i
mean
believe me as pittsburgh fans i i mean i
got to tell all my patriot fans i told
you so because when they got a b all of
them were like we got ap what's up yo
you guys and i'm like just wait
just wait he was great for one game yeah
i said i would give it two weeks and it
was actually one and how about brady
throwing it to le'veon i mean everybody
you can't you can't quit them joe
they're everywhere
they're everywhere but you're i love it
the nouveau riche
kansas city chief fan eric stonestreet
this is gonna be fun joe
this is going to be fun
all right so i'm glad you survived
yesterday congratulations on what an
insane insane day of football i mean uh
just just incredible
yeah i mean that that is uh
one last thing too joe i just want to
hit on for what you said before you said
you walked your dog your dog walks
[Music]
walks bubbles like touch the ground
that's about to say like you it seems
like you're constantly carrying bubbles
everywhere that little chihuahua yeah
the hairless chihuahua it seems like
bubbles is carried everywhere like you
actually leash this dog up and this
bubbles look at you say really you want
me to walk like your dog must not really
expect that oh yeah i mean well most of
the time she's perched on my shoulder
like a pirate parrot
but you know but not she's like she's
actually like really funny like in uh
very curious so she like she does run
around quite a bit especially like when
i was over in ireland for four months
like you know i'd take her to the park
and she just like run around and chase
pigeons and squirrels and stuff so yeah
there's bubbles
bubbles has made it on the screen right
here okay
all right joe you're the dream of you
having a los angeles super bowl with the
steelers in it is still alive right now
we're still here still alive and i want
to give a huge shout out to tj watt what
that was part of the emotional
rollercoaster of the day as well was he
gonna was he gonna
match or beat my buddy michael strahan
from magic mike xxl that's right
that's right
that's right straight was in that movie
yeah i remember believe me and listen
they they cut it out it was like 10
times as filthy like when they were just
soderbergh was just trying to keep
michael strahan's job with the way he
edited that are you so there's there's
there's soderbergh directors cut footage
that could derail everything that
strahan has built yeah it's like you
know like the snyder cut there there's a
that soderbergh get michael strahan
fired and he would he would never go to
outer space
[Laughter]
he wouldn't be allowed in orbit
do we need a hashtag should we get this
going
release the soderberg cut release the
soderberg cotton straight hands like no
way
yeah no way yeah did anything in that
soderberg cut look like the spaceship
that he took into space
is that wrong
well you know it's michael strahan got
got airborne at one point so i'll just
say yeah airborne he got some yeah he
got some lift off
what is happening
very good you can run your imagination
let it run wild joe mangalo joe mangano
everybody all right joe we'll chat soon
we'll chat soon thanks a lot oh and big
shout out to the mount lebanon high
school football team for winning the
pennsylvania state championship way to
go guys all right mount liebe there you
go
joe is is uh as rock solid to his roots
as anybody else all right joe uh by the
way i've already booked and this is
before you came on stone street's
supposed to be on next monday after the
game so he feels confident to say yes to
appear on this program the day after the
game the nouveau
there we go okay yeah we'll hear it
he'll have a week to formulate his
response i'm sure there we go well done
joe take care of yourself all right i'll
see you joe mangano everybody
the best what an answer
i would not i was not expecting that
he's old school i thought he'd be like
you know what we're playing i'd be
humble oh no he just went the exact
opposite which i know talks your
language i love it
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here